مره اخرى يفلت رئيس وزراء باكستان السابق
عمران خان من الاعتقال محكمه جنائيه تقضي
بالغاء مذكره الاعتقال ضده في قضيه فساد
وترفع الجلسه الى نهايه الشهر الجاري دون
توجيه لائحه الاتهام له بسبب الاضطرابات
والفوض التي رافقت المحاكمه فيما اتهم
عمران خان الحكومه بمحاوله اخصائه سياسيا
مثلت امام القضاء وكذلك افعل اليوم ما
تقوم به الحكومه يثبت سوءانيتها فلم يكن
هدفها من محاصره منزلي هو ضمان مثول امام
القضاء ولكن سجني وحرماني من المشاركه في
الانتخابات
جلسه المحاكمه ترافقت مع اقتحام الشرطه
منزل عمران خان في مدينه لاهور بسبب ما
وصفته تعطيل عمل قوات الامن السلطات
الباكستانيه حملت حزب الانصاف بزعامه
عمران خان مسؤوليه الازمه الحاليه واعلنت
مصادره اسلحه معتقان عناصر تخريبيه
لقد تمت اعاده فتح المنطقه المحظوره خارج
منزل عمران خان اعتقلنا ارهابيين وصدرنا
اسلحه وهذا يدل على عقليته انه ليس قائدا
سياسيا واعتقد ان الادله التي جمعناها
كافيه لحظر حزب عمران خان
محاكمه عمران خان شهدت حاله من الكر والفر
في محيط مبنى المحكمه الجنائيه في اسلام
اباد بين قوات الامن وانصار رئيس الوزراء
السابق تخللتها اعمال عنف وشغب وتبادل
فيها الطرفان الاتهامات بافتعال المواجهه
ويواجه عمران خان عده قضايا وبلغات تتعلق
باتهامات بالفساد واعمال العنف والارهاب
والتمرير غير القانوني وفيما تنفي الحكومه
صلتها يعتبرها عمران خان وانصاره غير
قانونيه وسوريه بالرغم من مرور نحو عام
على تنحيه رئيس الوزراء السابق عمران خان
عن رئاسه الحكومه الا انه لا يزال رقما
صعبا في المعادله الباكستانيه وتحديا جديا
للحكومه الحاليه فيما يحذر انصاره من ان
المساس به خط احمر عبد الرحمن المزيني
العربيه اسلام اباد